the Rebel Alliance insignia is a top her
tiny head I don't think I was an animal
person until I had these rabbits so
before the share is kind of going
through this like three to four year
isolation bin and then I met someone and
she happened to have one rabbit and ever
since then I just lost them to this
relationship we now lived together and
now we have two rabbits I'm here today
to get a tattoo of my daughter she's a
black cat named Jin
I picked the name Jin for a reason she's
named after the character in rogue one
Jin or so when I adopted Jen she was
actually adopted as a kitten by a family
the family ended up abandoning her and
she was literally found wandering the
streets in the rain it's so cheesy but
like I'm a cat lady and she's really one
of my best friends and I want her
immortalized on me forever
I am Adam parrot I'm a tattooer here in
Los Angeles California at rabble-rouser
tattoo I've been tattooing a little over
ten years I'm excited to give people
tattoos of their pets so they can have
them with them forever how's it going
I'm Adam I'm gonna beat your tattooer
what are you looking to do today I'm
getting my rabbit's tattoo today you're
what are their names so the big one is
named Gigi after thick black cat in
Kiki's Delivery Service and the little
one is keeping we are getting a tattoo
of my daughter who is a black cat it's
gonna be going on the back of my left
calf okay I'm looking to get something
on my arm I'm thinking like somewhere in
this area okay and then you mentioned
having it also framed
I'd love to have some kind of frame
around her I'm pretty much open to
anything as long as at the end of it
there's a cow on me okay cool thanks
guys
all right you ready to check it out all
right oh my god yes I love it that's
amazing I mean that looks exactly like
what they love eating Oh
I love it I want to put this in a lock
in it just like it's the [ __ ] getting it
on my calf we're just gonna do it on my
finger on it up awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're done check it out
oh yeah that's super amazing and it
looks so cute
can't wait to show my girlfriend and the
buddies yeah and the buns they're gonna
be the most excited about this oh my
goodness are you kidding it looks so
good it looks just like her somehow
you've captured like her eyes and her
dumb expression that she has in her face
constantly
the orange background is like what sets
it off this really turned out amazing
sweet awesome thanks man thank you so I
just got home from the tattoo shop and
I'm about to show my show and the buns
the tattoo I got today
you're really feeling me buns want to
tattoo I got so this is Jen's reaction
as I'm trying to show her that I've
committed to having her face on that leg
for life just disinterest and this is
Jen's reaction to the prospect of
getting a treat
[Music]